hi i'm alexis and i'm the senior food
specialist here at tasty today i'm going
to show you how to make my chicken
teriyaki crispy rice noodle bowl
[Music]
i love chicken teriyaki but it can often
feel so heavy to me and i wanted to make
it in a way that felt lighter and a
little more exciting so i think using
the fried noodles incorporating some of
these other really fresh toppings makes
it feel fresh and exciting while still
having that really incredible flavor
from the teriyaki sauce so to start this
recipe you're going to make the teriyaki
sauce it's really simple you're whisking
a few ingredients together and set it
aside
so i used really thin vermicelli noodles
for this so you want to make sure that
you're taking small portions of the
noodles off if you put the whole thing
in it's not going to fry correctly break
it apart take a handful of the dried
noodles before you start to fry you also
want to fry the noodles in batches so
that they all get evenly cooked if you
overcrowd the pan they're going to get
burnt so whenever you're frying you
really want to make sure it's the right
temperature so you get the right
consistency and that it cooks through we
tried frying these noodles at different
temperatures
and
too low and nothing happens they just
become like oily noodles if it's too
high the noodles will get brown really
fast so you really want to use a
thermometer
so the rice noodles are going to cook
really really fast as soon as they've
expanded you can use a slotted spoon to
remove them onto a sheet tray once you
fry the vermicelli noodles they just get
this incredible crunch which i
personally love so once your noodles are
fried you can move on to the chicken
gonna salt and pepper the chicken
add it to a wall
[Music]
and at this point then you're going to
add that reserved teriyaki sauce this
takes a few minutes and the chicken's
going to get really
shellacked with this incredible sauce
it's going to be
deep and flavorful and it's i mean it's
truly such a good sauce you could just
kind of drink it if you wanted
i think the joy of this dish is that it
has a ton of flavor but that it's really
easy to do frying sure will take a few
minutes but honestly you could do this
for under an hour this could be a
weeknight meal that's more interesting
than take out and it's more interesting
than your usual chicken teriyaki
[Music]
once you're done with the chicken you
can serve it over the noodles
[Music]
i added some stuff like snap peas
radishes scallions but you can top it
with whatever you like
you can also just make the chicken on
your own you could make the rice noodles
on their own and put other toppings
something like shrimp or vegetarian
stir-fry it's a really versatile recipe
these noodles are worth making on their
own the chicken teriyaki is worth making
on its own but if you make it and use
other ingredients other toppings let us
know in the comments we want to see what
you're making at home
[Music]
you